we have seen that this this polarized
atomistic thinking
about ourselves as individuals that our
self-definition matters a lot more our
feelings matter a lot more
than learning objective skills or
looking at the data or trying to figure
out true answers
that that has deep ramifications for
every area of our society
and it's just sort of glossed over
because here's the thing
most people don't look at the deep
substratum of thought here the deep
substrata of thought
when it comes to all the stuff that we
are hearing about the vocabulary as i
call it
the vocabulary is just a bunch of words
that we are taught to mimic so we can be
part of the upper class right i mean
that's really what it is that's what
college is all about these days it's why
you see people put
their pronouns in their twitter profiles
like i know you're a dude you don't need
to put he him
i know you're a chick you don't need to
put she her right if you're transgender
then maybe you will have a preferred
pronoun but the fact that you have a
bunch of people who are cisgender
putting pronouns in their profiles
is just a way of coding that you are a
member of this new upper crust elite who
speak
the vocabulary and that's all that
matters and americans want to be part of
that upper crust elite because americans
have always wanted to be part
of the new upper crust elite they've
wanted to be part of the new ruling
class it used to be that if you wanted
to be a member of the new ruling class
in the united states
what you would do is you would work
super hard and you dress really well
like above your station
right you'd wear a suit to the office
and you would try and get a nice wrist
watch
and you would learn to help you'd learn
the word of the day and you would try to
get a good education
right that was the way that you
demonstrated that you were a member of
the new ruling class
and more is change more race change and
so you see now that to be a member of
the new ruling class means to actually
dress down right if you're mark cuban
then you wear jeans and a t-shirt or if
you're mark zuckerberg you wear a hoodie
there are certain things that change but
the best way to become a part of the new
ruling class these days is to speak the
vocabulary it is just
the shave and a haircut two bits of
entry into the secret societies i've
said before
right when it comes to the use of these
terms it is not about understanding the
terms
most of the terminology does have a deep
academic background that is complete bs
but people don't have to know that and
they don't have to buy into it this is
why if you ask americans you believe
america is systemically racist
nobody understands what the term
systemically racist means because that
is a term that originated
in the centers of academia it has actual
content but it has been robbed of its
content for purposes of polling
all you know is that if you don't say
that america is systemically racist then
you will be labeled a racist and you can
never be part of the new ruling class
right that is why this sort of
vocabulary is used
this is why it is now dear gore for
prominent people to talk about how they
are embarrassed to be a member
uh to be a white person for example so
john brennan
who seriously ought to be in jail i mean
he lied to the senate openly lies in the
senate but john brennan is still
considered
a person worth listening to he was on
msnbc and he just throws out a comment
like this right he says he's embarrassed
to be a white male
why i mean seriously why i don't
understand why should you be embarrassed
of your skin color
i don't think whatever your skin color
you should be embarrassed of your skin
color it's bizarre
okay but this is now considered a way
into by saying that you're embarrassed
to be a white male you can actually be
super proud of yourself
being a white male who says he's
embarrassed to be a white male so here
is john brennan former cia director
saying this nonsense speaking the
vocabulary
i'm increasingly embarrassed to be a
white male these days
like what i see my other white male
saying but it just
shows that with the ex with very few
exceptions like mitt romney liz cheney
adam kinzinger
there are so few republicans in congress
who value
truth honesty okay all his rest of his
take on the republican party doesn't
matter at all
the the fact that nicole wallace you
know and everybody who's a white lady
is saying that that is laughing when he
says he's embarrassed to be a white male
question why why and that's ridiculous
even if a white person did something bad
why exactly would that embarrass you to
be a white male
that's like saying that every black
person should be embarrassed because
there are some black criminals that's
ridiculous
why would you why that has nothing to do
with you you're an individual
but again it's about speaking the
vocabulary and if you don't speak
the vocabulary then you can lose your
job you could have been a member of the
new ruling class one second ago but if
you don't speak the vocabulary then
you're out
which is what happened to donald mcneil
over at the new york times he has now
released this this long
four-part essay explaining why he was
fired from the new york times you'll
remember donald mcneil was the lead
coveted reporter at the new york times
he was nominated for
a pulitzer this year and he was ousted
from the new york times
for the great crime of having several
years ago gone on a trip to peru
where somebody asked him about the use
of the n-word by a 12-year-old girl
and he says well in what context was she
using that and he said the word
and he lost his job over that well he
was forced out he was forced out by the
editors at the new york times because he
had quote unquote lost the newsroom
first of all i don't even know how you
lose the newsroom who gives a crap with
the newsroom things
seriously you're the new york times
you're the leading newspaper in america
you give a crap with the quote news room
things about your lead reporter on covet
in the middle of a pandemic
but according to the washington free
beacon dean baquette the
the public the executive editor of the
paper said i know you're not a racist
but encouraged him to resign anyway
because he had quote unquote lost in the
newsroom but kat said we're not firing
you we're asking you to consider
resigning
although mcniel technically resigned his
own volition he was under intense
pressure to do so
when the star science reporter asked for
details about the allegations piquette
was silent
mcniel said it felt like an attempt to
intimidate me
apparently the new york times union was
unwilling to defend mcniel the union was
quote deeply split over my case
he decided he needed his own lawyer the
the reason
for all of this of course is because he
didn't speak the vocabulary
he said some things that were in
politics and if you say things that are
in politic
meaning they violate the precepts of the
woke
they violate the precept that facts
matter and the data matters then
like that entire incident was not about
him using the n-word the entire incident
was about him asking for specifics
you're not allowed to ask for specifics
because specifics provide clarity
generalities provide confusion
and room to wiggle right now all of
politics is about this
if you ask for specifics you are seen as
bad you are seen as wrong
you are seen as racist if you ask for
specifics you are seen as rebutting
somebody's deeply felt sense of personal
truth
and this is it's confusing stuff you can
violate
the strictures of the moment at any
point right twitch hilariously found
this out yesterday so twitch the
the streaming service they received
backlash from both liberals and
conservatives
after referring to women's history month
as wmx history month
w-o-m-x-n history month and now nobody
with a brain has ever referred to women
as w-o-m-x-n
but they were trying to make it that
women were different than than
woe men it's like so i married an actual
axe murderer
women whoa man
they basically then the trans community
came out and said this is terrible
because some women are men
so it's transphobic it's just it's
hilarious
it's hilarious like it's pretty
spectacular
that the that the woke can't even get it
straight but that's the whole point
and in the end that's the entire point i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
the subscribe button so you stay up to
date on all of our future content